its 2020 budget is
proposed and negotiated by the
fledgling commission but then negotiates the basis
for the transition from the current decade with a view to the next decade by the leyen commission in
its first year of work and office from the
final year of the applicable multiannual
budgetary framework
so when the final negotiations for the
budget framework for the years after
2020 began, it was not clear whether we could reach an
agreement
the signs were not really
pointing to a willingness to compromise and the ability to reach an agreement
that is why everyone
involved
i think it is strong that we are talking about this today as part of
the consilium period
results have come and this
budget points to the future
when the party on its way to
mature europe will invest 88 more next year and the amount is 88 percent more compared
to what will be spent on research and innovation
this year
the
starting point for me  hr research in the
next decade or connecting
europe facility energy infrastructures
on the way to the energy union for
maximum security of supply we are
increasing the funds
by 35% compared to the 19 in the interest of
gas and electricity security for the
european citizens and our
economic competitiveness
galileo our autonomy in terms of
satellites for
digital services navigation
weather forecasts civil protection plus
75 percent next
year compared to this year that means
we have proven programs
and a future in which we are investing more
than ever before and above all that was
very much in parliament  but also important for the
finnish government for climate protection
we are investing in everything from research to
infrastructure to other programs over
the next year 21 percent we
have agreed 20 percent for these
years
we are aiming for at least 25 percent in the
next decade at 21 we are
on the  the way there is a transitional
budget that will lead in the future and that
you can also represent excellently during the evening curfew
because it
sets the right priorities and thus
lays the financial foundations so that
europe in the von der leyen commission
and with the new parliament can
fulfill its tasks next year  can
hennig west at media
representativees